paixão aperta quase cega te domina a
queima da ard gana e em loket sim às
vezes provas tantos dramas noite sem
dormir pensamento sem fim
é uma viragem fascinante dasa imagina
assim impetuosa em si de zacher noia
feito calor do sol em mim mesmo assim no
meu coração sem razão se deixa seduzir e
se entrega
eu quero mais o amor real e que esteja
em paz
paixão aberta quase cega de domina
queimar diana
e vou kessy sim
às vezes trovas tantos dramas noite sem
dormir pensamentos em
é uma miragem fascinante dasa imagina
samba é impetuoso em sim em acessos
sendo olha feito calor do sol em mim
mesmo assim o meu coração
sem razão se deixa seduzir e se entregar
ae o amor real e que esteja em paz sem
razão e deixa cedo se e se entregar
háháhá
mas não ataca quase certa de domingo a
queima
ardin cana em ou quer sim às vezes
tramas tantos dramas noite sem dormir
meus amigos o chelsea é uma miragem
fascinante frágil imaginação' impetuosa
em si e nos acham
perfeito calor do sol em mim
assim meu coração sem razão se deixa
seduzir iria se entregar
a mãe
o mesmo nome
[Música]
é a dose e se entregar
i e ii
[Música]
hum
mas